So I started off this process by
assigning some variables I already knew.
So the height being eight is
just kind of a default value for
the height of a basement.
It could've been seven,
it could've been nine.
Anything that's tall enough
that we can fit in it is fine.
For the total width and
the total length we were actually given
those over here in the requirements.
The length is 44 and the width is 30.
Those are set by the other
floors of the house, and
the basement just kind of
mimics their footprint.
So, what I did next, was that I just
went ahead and took the requirements for
the utility closet and the stairwell and
went ahead and applied them.
I just said that the utility closet and
the stairwell must each
be 100 square feet.
Let's just keep these simple and
go ahead and
assign those 10 by 10 for each.
Similarly for the bathroom, the bathroom
must be at least 200 square feet.
And no length or
width can be under 10 feet.
Let's just make it 10 by 20,
that's pretty easy.
After assigning those three rooms,
we had 920 square feet left, so
I decided to keep things
simple here as well,
split it in two,
two rooms that are each 460 square feet.
And one way to do that would
be to make them each 20 by 23.
So some of you might notice that
these rooms don't actually map to
the 44 by 30 basement, because while the
areas of these rooms add up to the same
number of square feet, they aren't
configurable into the right arrangement.
For the purposes of this
example we'll be using numbers.
But, a real configuration exercise for
this would also involve
arranging the rooms.
So, not only do they add to
the same number of square feet, but
they can also fit inside
the same rectangle.
>> Thank you, David.
There are several things to
note from David's analysis.
One is that in configuration
final we want an arrangement
of all the components of all the parts.
So in this case, finally we want
an arrangement of all the rooms and
these stairwells and
these utility closets and so on.
Not just the size of each one of them,
but the actual spatial layout.
Second, they would begin by assigning
values to some variables here
because he thought that this
variables were more restricted.
One can use a number of different
heuristics for ordering the variables.
Perhaps we can choose those variables
which are most restricted first.
Or we can choose those variables
that restrict others the most first.
We can choose the most
important variables first.
The point is there can be
a large number of variables and
we can impose an ordering on them.